on vous parle aujourd'hui de
l'endométriose cette maladie
gynécologique causée par la présence de
cellules de l'endomètre en dehors de
l'utérus elle touche actuellement une
femme sur dix en france et près de la
moitié se plaignent de douleurs intenses
dans le bas du ventre dans certains cas
extrêmement invalidantes et pouvant même
entraîner l'infertilité julia cigare
bonjour je vais vous décrypter pour nous
un ce mal qui touche donc une femme sur
dix en autres deux pays la part des
femmes touchées est extrêmement
importante aujourd'hui oui effectivement
on dit souvent que 10% et des femmes
sont touchées par l'endométriose mais vu
que le diagnostic est souvent très long
on dit que le temps moyen de diagnostic
et de sept ans et on y reviendra dans un
instant avec notre invité pour
comprendre exactement pourquoi eh bien
on estime aujourd'hui que ce chiffre
pourrait être revu à la hausse et être
plutôt autour de 10 à 15% des femmes
alors que se passe-t-il vous savez que
l'utérus est tapissée d'une muqueuse qui
s'appelle l'endomètre qui est constituée
elle de deux cellules en fait qui vont
contribuer à la nidation de l'offre lors
de la fécondation donc si il y à
fécondation les cellules de l'endomètre
vont s'épaissir vont se réunir et former
ce que l'on appelle la dentelle utérine
donc nécessaire à la nidation si il n'y
a pas de fécondation et bien tout
simplement sa dentelle utérine va
s'évacuer par hémorragie par par le
vagin est donc ce sont ce que l'on
appelle les règles tout simplement et
bien en cas dans le cas de
l'endométriose qui se passe c'est que
les cellules de l'endomètre vont en fait
ce ne sont pas des cellules dans l'antre
de mettre ces sont des cellules qui sont
similaires sans blabla l'endomètre qu'on
se trouvait en fait en dehors de
l'utérus comme vous l'avez vu voilà sur
sur ce schéma et à chaque cycle donc le
sens et les cellules ne vont pas pouvoir
s'éliminer et donc ça va induire
effectivement une réaction inflammatoire
cycliques et locales ce qui explique
justement est des douleurs intenses
alors des 10% de femmes qui sont
aujourd'hui touchées par l'endométriose
40% des crimes effectivement des
douleurs pelvic très importante faut
savoir certaines ne pouvant pas se lever
même un absolument c'est ça ressemble en
fait elles décrivent souvent que ça peut
aller jusqu'à ressembler à des
contractions de d'accouchement
cdd douleur aussi dans le bas du dos
dans dans le bas du ventre et ça peut
aller jusqu'à l'évanouissement dans
certains cas le mécanisme exact de
l'endométriose n'est pas connu souvent
on donne 7 cette explication que je
viens de vous donner mais il y aurait
peut-être aussi des facteurs génétiques
et pourquoi pas des facteurs immunitaire
alors il faut savoir que vous avez
certaines femmes qui vont avoir ces
crises d'endométriose pendant leurs
règles d'autres même 20 mois sur 20
jours excusez moi pendant le mois donc
ça peut être vraiment différent et
surtout que ceux ci c'est cellule
semblable à l'endos mais très bien
peuvent aussi migrer dans d'autres
organes comme par exemple le colon la
vessie ou encore dans certains cas c'est
plus rare mais dans les poumons alors
pour en savoir plus je vous propose
elisabeth de nous tourner vers notre
invité yasmine camp nou lé présidente
dando france bonjour et bienvenue est ce
que vous pouvez nous expliquer pourquoi
la maladie est si méconnu et surtout
pourquoi il est encore difficile de le
diagnostiquer
bonjour et merci pour cette invitation
alors je pense qu'on a trop longtemps
banaliser la douleur des femmes pendant
leur règle pour pour comprendre que
c'est un symptôme en fait qui annonce
peut-être landry trio est le deuxième
point important c'est que les médecins
eux mêmes vous n'ont pas bénéficié d'une
formation adéquate souvent dans les
crises beaucoup considèrent encore que
c'est une maladie à la mode ou qu'une
jeune femme de 20 ans ne peut pas avoir
d'endroit maîtrise parce qu'elle est
trop jeune qui a un problème de
formation des médecins alors on sait
aujourd'hui que l'endométriose peut
provoquer de nombreux symptômes dans 30
à 40 % des cas même l'infertilité alors
quelles sont justement les cintres les
symptômes les plus courants qui devrait
alerter
alors dans 70 % des cas c'est vraiment
une douleurs invalidantes comme vous
l'avez dit miller qui ressemble à des
contractions un d'accouchement une
douleur qui empêchent d'agir au
quotidien et qui résistent un simple
antalgiques ça c'est une douleur qui
n'est pas normal ensuite en fonction des
localisation des lésions d'endométriose
ou pourra avoir des troubles urinaires
des troubles digestifs des douleurs
pendant les rapports homosexuels
une fatigue chronique des douleurs
lombaire des douleurs pelviennes des
douleurs dans les jambes et puis dans
certains cas en fonction des atteintes
aux plus rares que vous évoquiez des
primes au thorax qui sont signes
d'atteinte thoracique août vers
pragmatique alors yasmine quels sont les
traitements qui existent aujourd'hui que
l'on peut proposer aux femmes qui sont
atteintes d'endométriose
alors aujourd'hui la haute autorité de
santé et les experts de l'endométriose
préconise le traitement qui va stopper
les règles puisqu'on a bien compris
comme vous l'expliqué que quand on a nos
règles et bien les zooms qui sont dans
le ventre elles vont saigner aussi ça va
créer des micro hémorragies qui vont
être responsable des douleurs des kystes
d adhérence des nodules qui vont chaque
mois se propage et donc stoppé les
règles m en aménorrhée ça évite sayid
cela cela n'a rien à voir avec la
ménopause artificielle parce que
beaucoup confondent encore
associé à cela en complément bien sûr il
ya le traitement antalgique puisqu'il
faut faire taire aussi la douleur et
puis bien sûr c'est assez d'un dialogue
avec le médecin
luna juste les traitements mais souvent
il ya un traitement chirurgical quant au
traitement médical ne suffit pas et là
il doit être mené par des experts et en
complément au quotidien il y à tout ce
qu'on peut mettre en oeuvre pour lutter
contre la douleur provoquée par l'elysée
ward 11 sa va être par exemple de la
sophrologie de l'hypnose de la
relaxation du biogaz des séquences avec
un kiné ou
un ostéopathe qui vont permettre de
redonner de la mobilité aux organes et
d'atténuer les adhérences ça va être
aussi le sport adapté tout ce qui va
aider à gérer la douleur et le stress
sont vraiment important dans la prise en
charge pour qu'ils diraient de leur
groupe
yasmine candau et merci infiniment
d'avoir répondu à nos questions
merci elizabeth comme vous l'avez vu un
c il y à une nécessité de changer de
mentalité vraiment parce que pendant
longtemps on a on n'a vraiment pas
compris cette maladie il faut savoir que
c'est ça change vraiment c'est très
invalidants au niveau du quotidien au
point où une journée de travail et est
absolument incompatibles donc là ce qui
est intéressant c'est que le
gouvernement vient de lancer une
stratégie nationale contre
l'endométriose qui enfin enfin reconnaît
la maladie comme une affection longue
durée et qui fait qu'on en parle
beaucoup plus